president trump is leaving the door open
for more stimulus talks with democrats
after
acting on his own to help americans pay
their bills
we've had it and we're going to save
american jobs and provide
relief to the american workers that i'll
be signing the executive actions he
signed on saturday include federal
unemployment benefits of 400 a week
if states pay part of that cost that's
lower than the 600
weekly check that some 30 million
americans collected
until the program expired last month
the president also acted to defer the
payroll tax for most working americans
he will look at halting evictions and
foreclosures
and plans to extend federal student loan
relief house speaker nancy pelosi says
the president's moves
are not enough and probably are not
legal
so the president's meager
weak and unconstitutional actions
further
demand that we have an agreement speaker
pelosi and other top democrats want to
revive
talks with republicans that failed on
friday at this time
no new talks are scheduled for more on
the president's executive action we're
joined by chief washington correspondent
major garrett he's also the host of the
take out and the debrief podcast
major good morning we just heard nancy
pelosi but the pushback has actually
been bipartisan
republican senator ben sasse of nebraska
called the executive orders
unconstitutional slop
so what is the president actually trying
to accomplish here
look the president loves headlines
declarations and the appearance of
action
so what his supporters hear is congress
is stuck there's an impasse the
president acted that's the headline
that's the declaration you'll let from
the white house
all this week congress didn't move and
the president did
the problem for the white house is most
of these interventions
are complicated some are unworkable many
could be challenged in court
so if the president wants to sort of
shock the system and get negotiations
up and running again this isn't much
voltage it's kind of like static
electricity
memorably for a moment you remember it
but it's mostly annoying and doesn't
really solve the problem
yeah and well does he actually have the
power to do this
in some cases he does this move on
payroll taxes
resembles it's not exact but it
resembles something that president obama
did during the great recession
so there is some legal authority there
but it is unclear
if businesses will follow this because
they want to know
that they can actually withhold these
payroll taxes if they do
people's paychecks will be slightly more
generous but on the other things with
evictions
college age most of those things are
memorandums intentions from the
president
no real legislative language everyone in
washington knows
if you want to solve these problems you
have to legislate not send executive
memos because a lot of people are
feeling
kind of desperate right now major with
with some of this due to expire i mean
how much help is actually in here for
people
well let's look at the unemployment
benefits it is dependent on states
finding the revenue to supplement what
the federal government is going to
provide the federal government will
provide that by the way by taking money
away billions of dollars from
disaster relief assistance so if there's
more hurricanes
which the national weather service
predicts we will have or wildfires
that's going to be depleted so that's a
problem
and states right now all of them are
financially strapped why because the
lockdowns have depleted their revenue
stores
so even if the president is successful
it will be
required for states to step in and
assist him
many can't do that that is one of the
very reasons this is problematic and
probably won't provide the aid
on unemployment benefits americans need
right now
you say any long-lasting relief will
have to come from congress what's the
prospect
of that now major given their
differences
congressional democrats see this as
action and they know the president will
grab and did grab some headlines they
need to reengage with the white house
the white house also knows this is not
sufficient to meet the economic test
that the pandemic continues to press for
the country
so negotiations will likely resume
congress has not res uh
uh gone on recess for the summer as it
typically does
lawmakers are waiting for resolution and
specifically
senate republicans up for re-election
need something to vote for
by acting with executive memoranda the
president is leaving them in the cold
they need a deal as much as the white
house does you'll see pressure from
senate republicans
to restart talks